so today we're gonna talk about the
benefits of apple cider vinegar all
right so what is episode of vinegar
basically you're taking the sugar in the
apple juice in certain microbes bacteria
and yeast are turning that sugar into
alcohol then eventually into vinegar so
there's a whole process that occurs and
the end product vinegar is acetic acid
now there's other acids involved but
this is the main one
so remember growing up in Wisconsin
where there was farms all around our
neighborhood and so we had a crabapple
tree and there was a farmer on the other
side of the cornfield so I brought him a
big bushel basket of crab apples and I
wanted him to grind up these apples and
turn them into apple juice so he did
that for me I brought him back in jugs
and I left him out in the Sun I think
one or two days and they turned into
something called apple cider apple cider
is basically a spiked apple juice okay
it had some alcohol in it and that
basically was the start of my alcoholic
journey at eight years old and I'm
completely being sarcastic so I did not
become an alcoholic at eight years old
more like twenty years old no I'm just
kidding but the point is that if you
take apple juice that's not pasteurized
not heated it goes through fermentation
okay so with the help of microbes it
eventually turns into vinegar so there's
many different types of vinegar that you
can get the one I'm gonna recommend is a
raw unpasteurized version of vinegar
organic Bragg's has a really good one it
also has the mother what is that that's
basically some residue of some fiber
pectin
some bacteria in yeast I do not think
that's going to give you a lot of health
benefits really the health benefits are
the acetic acid but the fact that the AB
set of vinegar is raw means that it's
going to be rich in enzymes so that
alone can actually help you in your
digestion so you don't want it
pasteurized and the other thing that
because it's organic means it doesn't
have the added pesticides in the
chemical so Bragg's is a really good
version also the pH is between three
point three and three point five if you
get distilled vinegar it's a little bit
lower I think it's like two point five
but this is acid enough
all right so the other thing is you
don't need to keep it in the fridge
shredder you can keep it outside the
refrigerator and it'll last for like
five years okay so now let's talk about
the benefits of outside of Ana here
number one digestion it speeds up
digestion it activates enzymes so a lot
of these enzymes in the stomach in the
pancreas and other places in the body
are dormant and it takes certain things
to activate them and acid is one of the
activators of the enzymes in the stomach
to help you break down protein so right
there that's going to help speed up
digestion number two it's going to
control pathogens if you think about it
you have pickles you have fermented
vegetables that are in acid that acid in
there is preserving that food and
preventing bacterial growth so when you
consume an acid actually lowers the
pathogens in the body that helps in the
overgrowth of certain microbes
especially even a condition called C Bo
si Bo small intestinal bacterial
overgrowth which is a condition where
you have bacteria growing in the wrong
place you have all this bacteria growing
in the small intestine instead of the
large intestine and so if your pH is not
strong enough in the stomach you can
actually develop that condition so if
you take outside of vinegar it can help
create a condition where the microbes
cannot thrive in the small intestine
number three it helps you absorb
minerals like calcium magnesium and iron
all need certain pH to be absorbed if
the pH in your stomach is too alkaline
you're not going to absorb as many
minerals also vitamins vitamin K vitamin
C and even b12 need this acid to be
absorbed all right number four it can
decrease gas bloating and even
indigestion so the last thing you want
is undigested food in your in your
digestive tract so outside of vinegar
just speeds up the breakdown of food so
you have more of a complete digestion
one cause of gas is incomplete protein
digestion alright number five it
decreases acid reflux now normally what
happens in the stomach is you have to
have an acid up between one and three
very very acidic to be able to have that
valve on the top close and prevent the
backup of acid that comes in your
esophagus so when you lose your stomach
acid the valve doesn't close and the
acid can reflux up and the term for that
is GERD and so you would take in any
asset and you feel better but the next
time you eat it's worse why because
you're making that acid less acid and so
over time that valve just stays open and
you have a constant reflux and you're
dependent on these medications well
here's the thing if you take apple cider
vinegar it helps the valve closed more
improving the symptoms of acid reflux
and GERD the exact opposite thing you
would think that would work but it does
work now even if you look at the side
effects of taking medication for acid
reflux and GERD is GERD it's the same
thing so the side effect is that you get
at more acid reflux it doesn't make
sense okay so number six it helps to
release bile the bile is made in your
liver and it's released from the
gallbladder and there's a certain signal
from the stomach of having a certain
amount of acid that then triggers the
release of the bile
so alpha cider vinegar can help release
the bile that's congested that's why you
probably have less bloating when you
take it also the enzymes from the
pancreas can release so you have more
complete digestion alright number seven
you get more of a complete breakdown
with protein so the protein can then
turn into its amino acids which are the
building blocks of protein and you need
a certain acid to activate the enzymes
to do that okay episode of vinegar can
contribute to those acids number eight
blood sugar improvement episode vinegar
can help you make glucose more sensitive
so you have less insulin resistance and
thereby less insulin being produced and
that can directly cause more weight loss
so when you hear these claims about
episode of vinegar helping you lose
weight this is why also it's going to
help you lower cholesterol why because
when you reduce insulin you lower
cholesterol it's probably going to also
help with blood pressure and anything
related to high levels of insulin it can
improve okay and lastly it can help your
immune system it can stimulate the white
blood cells to speed up and help fight
infection so as you can see there are
many benefits outside of vinegar so go
ahead and take between one and two
tablespoons outside of vinegar in some
water I usually use 16 ounces I like to
put lemon juice in there as well you can
use a straw so it doesn't affect your
teeth and you can take it before a meal
after a meal I take mine in the evening
right about 6:00 o'clock as you take my
wheatgrass juice at powder in the
morning and I'll take this in the
evening but in summary there's many
benefits to this product and if you
don't like the taste you can also get it
into a tablet form and I'll put a link
down below if you want to take it in a
pill form alright guys thanks for
watching I'll see in the next video so
if you want more knowledge on how to
create a healthy body subscribe now and
get daily notifications daily
notifications that sounds weird well
I'll just remind you on a daily basis
how about that